and Rob is a great guy we had our our  relationship what's in the past of the  past  Adrienne Bailon set the record straight  about rumors she cheated on ex Rob  Kardashian what I will say is that girl  was certainly not me  it just saying hey I actually never  cheated on Rob I'll explain the reason  behind his struggles with jealousy in  China I had a really bad past  relationship where the girl was cheating  and having sex with so many different  people like for what he's saying though  okay I will say this I think anybody  that's been in a relationship where they  were cheated on or hurt um it affects  you yeah and if it affected me so much  that I made it a conscious decision to  not do that the next person you are  cheated on let's have fun it yes what  [ __ ] that's all news Bryan cheated on  the half Adrian has since moved on from  Rob with Beyonce is real hot we've come  such a long way congratulations